we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is a caller who is
not happy with my analysis about the
Kanye West anti-Semitism situation from
yesterday listen to this
hi um so I was watching today's episode
uh from November 1st and I found it a
little bit problematic
um how confidently
uh David speaks on the motive of where
like Kanye's anti-Semitism is absolutely
abhorrent and unacceptable no exceptions
full stop yes but you really need a
medical
um expertise of of some kind to be able
to assume that his anti-Semitism isn't
coming from the mental illness because
it's actually incredibly common uh with
bipolar type 2 and
schizophrenia that they have very
conspiratorial beliefs
um I've had friends who have gotten sick
and then gotten better and believed very
unhinged conspiratorial things we should
also keep in mind that Kanye has a lot
of distaste and a lot of distrust for
black people as well and the black lives
matter movement yeah so listen let me
address this
what is the point that I was making
yesterday think back to Mel Gibson Mel
Gibson got completely drunk and got
pulled over
and he immediately said to the cop are
you a Jew and he went on an anti-semitic
ramp
and then it was blamed on the alcohol
and one of the things that was widely
accepted at the time was drinking didn't
make Mel Gibson anti-semitic it's not
that you without being exposed to
anti-semitic conspiracy theories you
drank and suddenly you believed the Jews
controlled banking right the alcohol
can't make you it has to be in there
already and so the point with Kanye is
yes people become paranoid and
conspiratorial when they are suffering
from a number of different mental
illnesses but the things about which
they become conspiratorial aren't
planted there and what I'm saying is if
you lived outside of a society in which
anti-semitic tropes and beliefs were
perpetuated you could start suffering
from bipolar II and your paranoia would
be about the police walk watching you or
something that is there already that you
are aware of you you're not all of a
sudden gonna be absent having that
information or those claims somewhere
already
you're not going to start believing
those particular things simply because
you drink too much or you start having a
manic episode or whatever the case may
be that's the point so what I there is
no doubt that we're we're Kanye
better mental health wise
he very well might not be saying these
things and might not even think them to
the degree that he does
but these are beliefs that we know have
been floating around in Kanye's head for
a long time and that's the point that I
was trying to make on the bonus show
today we will talk about
jair bolsonaro signaling he will
cooperate with the transfer of power but
not conceding defeat we're going to talk
about a total lockdown at Shanghai
Disneyland in China wild situation and
we will talk about a Democratic
candidate who was beaten and knock
knocked unconscious in his home that's
Richard ringer this is crazy all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com